hey this is presh talwalker a man
started from home at 14 30 hours and
drove to a village when he arrived the
village clocked displayed 15-15 hours
after staying for 25 minutes he returned
home by a different route the route
length was 1.25 times the first route
but he drove two times as fast he
reached home at 1600 hours
compared to the clock at home is the
village clock running fast or slow and
by how many minutes
a version of this problem was on a civil
services exam in India
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
recall the formula that distance is
equal to rate times time which is often
abbreviated as D is equal to R times t
in this case we will solve for t to get
T is equal to D over r
so let's sketch the situation A Man is
leaving home and his clock is showing 14
30.
he drives to the village and the village
clock is showing 1515.
he then Waits 25 minutes in the village
so the village clock would show 1540.
he then takes a drive home
now let's say the route to The Village
had a distance D and he drove at a rate
r
on the way home the distance is 1.25 D
and the speed is twice as fast so it'll
be 2R
and we know he reaches home and his
clock says 1600 hours
so in order to compare the two clocks we
have to know the time at home
at the same time we know the time in the
village
so ideally we'd like to figure out the
time that he reaches the village what is
the clock at home showing
so how can we figure out the time it
takes him to go to the Village
well one thing we do know is the total
trip time goes from 1430 to 1600 so this
is 90 minutes
we also know the relative distances and
rates at which he went to and from the
village so from this we might be able to
figure out the time that he took to get
to the Village
so let's set up an equation
we know the total trip time is 90. so we
want the time to the Village the time
you spent in the village and the time
returning so the time it took him to get
to the Village was D over r
he then spent 25 minutes in the village
and it took him 1.25 D over 2R to return
home
so let's solve this equation for D over
r
we subtract 25 from both sides to get 65
is equal to D over R plus 5 over 8
multiplied by D over R this is a total
of 13 over 8 multiplied by D over r
we then multiply by the reciprocal 8
over 13 to get the D over R is equal to
65 multiplied by 8 over 13 and that's
equal to 40 minutes
so when he left home at 1430 it took him
exactly 40 minutes to get to the Village
so we can then solve that the clock at
home would have been showing 1510 at the
time he reached the village
so it's 1510 at the clock at home versus
15 15 for the clock in the village
therefore the village clock is running
five minutes faster than the clock at
home and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time